salut ça vous arrive souvent de flipper
d'avoir une angoisse eh bien aujourd'hui
j'ai invité un grand médecin un grand
toubib non pas du tout j'ai invité
un comédien pour nous parler de
trac et c'est Rudy Milstein
salut salut salut
vous allez bien
j'ai l'impression qu'on va passer un bon moment de rigolade -c'est ca
non pas du tout
on va vous parler du traque aujourd'hui c'est parti générique
Tout au long de l'année régulièrement  dans les commentaire vous m'avez demandé
si j'avais des trucs ou des astuces pour
gérer le trac
et le trac c'est quelque chose qu'on vit souvent on le vie en milieu professionnel
personnel
y a pas que sur la scène
mais quand même comme rudy c'est un
excellent comédien
mais si c'est vrai je t'ai vu dans les malheurs de Rudy  j't'ai vu dans copains comme cochon
cousin cousins comme cochons
Ah ben oui j'ai pris la bonne citation
Mais ça *rires*
tu veux que je coupe ça
et je l'ai vu dans pleins d'autres choses j'ai été obligé de couper
dans des grand théâtre il n'a pas tout assumer mais taper Rudy dans YouPorn et vous verez
de quoi on parle
et donc alors du coup eh ben alors je te laisse gérer je rigole
je le fais chier depuis tout à l'heure parce que la tu vois
Rudy est en train de vivre vraiment du trac
alors est-ce que toi avant de monter sur scène en vrai  juste pour te présenter
un peu mieux t'es comédiens
tu fait pas mal de choses sur scène
tu fait pas mal de choses avec l'atelier Palmade
-ouais -tu as tourné dans un long métrage -ouais 2-3
2-3 c'est vrai
mais peut-être qu'on ne connaissaient pas
avant
pour les deux autres
si m alors il ya eu le film de Clovis Cornillac  un peu beaucoup aveuglément
mais j'ai été coupé au montage
et en faite si tu vois le film tu me vous juste rigoler
*rires*
le mec qui fais t'as pas cité tous les films ok donc si tu vois le film tu me vois juste faire comme ça
et après la scène dans la quel j'été a ete coupé
et après j ai joué dans le film de Julie Delpy
ou j'aipas été coupé et la j'ai joué dans un film qui n'est pas encore sorti
qui va sortir au printemps ah ben oui mais non mais c'est pour ça
qui s'appel ? Embrasse-moi
*rire* on en ai pas encore là
c'est terrible tout le monde veut faire cette vanne en faite
ouais mais même moi que je le dis j ai toujours  un moment de ...
est-ce que t'as du trac avant
de monter sur scène avant un tournage
avant une interview avant quelque chose
-ouais  -est ce que c'est une émotion que tu connais
ah ben ouais tout le temps même dans
la vie tout le temps
et ça se traduit comment chez toi
je sens c'est quand c'est là
tous viens ici tous se mets là
d'accord c'est plus du
tout le corps qui parle et du coup c'est
tout le mental qui vient tout contrôler
donc en fait tu te sens dissociation
ouais quand je sors du corps je sens que d'un coup je suis là
et je fais ok
quel pose je prends ça se vois tout de suite je le vois tout de suite en plus comme je suis grand
donc du coups t'es là ça non ça va pas ça s'est pas naturel
qui m'as mis ce bras ici t'es la comme ca donc t'as l'impression que c'est plus ton corps tu as des degrés différents de trac
qui va de
de je me contrôle à une angoisse totale
y a
des degrés différents mais à partir du moment où je me contrôle c'est que y a un manque
de confiance ouais
- quels sont tes solution dans ces cas
là pour faire baisser ses émotions
d'angoisse
est ce que tu as des rituels est ce que tu as des trucs -ouais
dites-nous tout
les gens veulent savoir les abonnés
cherche à savoir
et en même temps ils sont en train de chercher le nom des films sur internet
ils sont en train de taper YouPorn
rire
euh la respiration
ouais je respire par le nez
ouais -je visualise...   habituellement plutot par les oreilles
non j ai une déformation de la cloison nasale
je me suis fait opérer l'année dernière l'année dernière donc y a deux ans j'ai récupéré la respiration par le nez
avant je n'arrivais pas à respirer par le nez
par le nez par le ventre aussi oauis c'est ca
de visualiser le souffle qui passe
et d'un coup ça me permet de me
remettre ben c'est des trucs de méditations
de ce centre ouais on avait
parlé de choses comme ça quand on
avait parlé de de se relaxer qu'on
avait parlé de focaliser sur sa
concentration
en fait ça c'est un bon truc qui marche qui est facile à faire quand
vous commencez a être un peu angoissé que ça va pas que ça vous prends à la tête ou au ventre
y en a beaucoup qui ressentent le trac par le
ventre
la diarrhée la chiasse  merci je voulais pas le dire
alors la il y a une explication scientifique
en général quand un animal a peur et nous quand on avais peur
le meilleur moyen pour faire
fuir l'adversaire c'est de le dégouter
par l'odeur - mais non c'est vrai c'est ça -donc on a le sphincter qui se relache
c'est pour ça que si tu te fais agresser dans la rue y a un mec qui arrive avec un couteau tu peux vraiment
littéralement te chier dessus
mais ça c'est le cerveau reptilien qui prends les commandes
et c'est nos reflex
animalier scphincter qui se dilate
pour -en gros tu te pisse dessus quand ta peur
moi ça m'arrive souvent les gens le savent
je suis transparent avec vous -d'accord c'est génial je savais pas
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant ça vous intéresse ben moi ça m'intéresse
du coup la respiration parce que je sais exactement
de quoi on parler
je prends des notes dans ma tête vous
pouvez faire cette chose très simple
donc quand ça commence à venir à la
tête ou dans le ventre
de respirer par le nez mais de
visualiser vraiment le souffle qui rentre
de visualiser arriver dans les
poumons pouvez même visualiser
l'échange
de toute cet oxygéne rentre qui
se rechargent après des choses un peu
plus négative le CO2 toutes ces
choses-là et de visualiser l'expiration
par le nez ou par la bouche
mais en plus de ça
en se focalisant dessus
des gens pensent à autre chose on
revient sur l'instant présent et non
pas sur les projections de peur
et puis ça va vous de
redonner un rythme cardiaque en
réalité ça va vous réoxygénée
mais ça c'est très facile à faire
ouais même tu parles de théâtre ou
de tournage tout ça mais même dans
l'avion j'ai avant j'avais pas du tout peur de l'avion
avion et en fait je me suis rendu compte
au fur et a mesure je flipper vraiment beaucoup en avion
en un jour je lisais le pouvoir
du moment présent dans l'avion
de qui es jusqu'ici d'Eckhart Tolle
voici le  pouvoir de l'instant présent
je vous le mettrais dans la description
et donc j'étais dans l'avion et puis il parlais
d'un coup de ça
du moment juste de respirer de revenir dans son corps
et je faisais ça
et d'un coup
j'étais... ca a pris un peu de temps
le temps de comprends d'intégrer tout
ça
et en fait d'un coup j'étais hyper bien dans cet avion j'avais plus du tout peur
ici et maintenant -et du coup
j'étais pas dans des
projection de
on va s'écraser
c'est marrant parce que tu vois je je je
pensais pas qu'on allait aborder sur la
vidéo
mais effectivement en fait
en faisant ça
tu traites complètement la
cause
du trac et non pas les symptômes
et la cause du trac c'est toujours des especes
de projection de peur de ce qui
peut mal se passer donc si tu coupes ça
en te ramenant tout de suite dans la
réalité et non pas dans ce que
pourrait être le futur proche
y'a meme plus de trac et plus de symptômes et puis de
se mettre dans son
corps aussi ça évite d'être dans des projections de ce que pensent
les autres
parce que tu te mets souvent dans le corps des autres
*rire* www.YouPorn/RudyMilstein
on vous l'a dis
*rire*
arrete y a ma mere qui va regarder - c'est vrai salut mme Milstein c'est pas vrai
c'est sur pornub
non pas dans le corps des autres dans la tête des autres
t'es dans un projection de ce qui vont penser de toi
et sur scène souvent y a ça tu te dis au bout de la 150ème
quand tu connais exactement les
réactions du public tu dis si si
des parfois si t'es pas bien dans le moment si tu t'amusent pas vraiment
t'es juste dans ah merde ils ont moins ils ont moins réagi que d'habitude ils ont moins rigoler que
habitude
et en fait c'est pas bon t'es dans un truc ok t'es dans une
projection de ce qu'ils pensent
alors que si juste t'es dans tu fais ce truc de respiration t'es dans ton corps
et que tu t'en fous
t'es pas dans les projections mentales
ben tu t'en fout en fait si ça rigole moins tu t'en fous tu fais ton truc
tu t'amuses t'es dedans -vous savez quoi je vais synthétiser
2 conseils de Rudy
je parle mal
non c'est qu'on parle trop c'est qu on parle trop surtout
le premier c'est de faire un petit
exercice de respiration aussi simple
que celui dont on vient de parler
et le deuxième c'est de ne pas
faire d'hypothèses en faite
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez j'avais fait une
vidéo sur les accords toltec
vous pouvez la retrouvez vous tapez fabien olicard
accord toltec
et deux des accords toltec sont pas faire d'hypothèses
et de ne pas en faire une affaire
personnelle
et en fait c est à peu près ça -oui c'est ça -si tu mixes les 3
après ça va ça va mieux est-ce que tu
connais des personnes qui ont d'autres
rituels comme ça qui serait
intéressant ou amusant à dire
je ne regarde pas les autres je m'en fous des autres *rire* je suis très égoïste - je vous ai pas dis je m'autocentré
j'en ai rien à branler des autres -mais non mais en plus tout les comédiens que je vois avec qui je joue
si c'est toujours ce truc la de respiration
de concentration après ça se manifeste de
manière différente chacun si y a
qui sont
ils se mettent à l'aise en faisant des blagues
en se mettent dans un truc détendu donc
en amenant la détente
ils s'amenent la détente en la forçant un peu en faisant des blagues en rigolant en faisant tout ça quoi
ce'esthyper intérésent comme discussion on
sent bien qu'on pourra en parler très
longtemps néanmois ça va être
beaucoup trop long pour vous déjà je
pense que cette vidéo va passer les dix
minutes
et  vous remarquerais qu'il n'y a pas de
coupure publicitaire dans mes vidéos
qui dépassent les 10 minutes c'est pas pour
ça merci beaucoup Rudy d'être venu se
soir à la maison parce qu'on est
hier soir au moment où vous voyez cette vidéo
oui merci c'est cool - eh ben non merci à toi -c'est bien d'avoir l'avis de
quelqu'un qui est souvent sur les
planches et qui a le stress aussi
de de de tourner dans des
long-métrage et tout parce c'est
on pense souvent à ça au trac comme
tu l'as si bien rappelé c'est aussi
dans le quotidien même des
fois le fait d'aller parler à quelqu'un
qui nous plaît où quelque chose comme ça
alors vous pouvez faire ses exercices de
respiration
et ne pas émettre d'hypothèses de pas aller
comme tu dissais dans le cerveau de l'autre
pour essayer de penser à sa place
pensez à vous
fait le truc
qui fait le moment et ça va vous aider
à diluer le stress
est ce que c'était pas mortel -mais c'est génial parce que tu as tout synthétiser et ce qui est fous
c'est qu'on en a pas parler avant
des trucs de méthodes mais qu'en fait
on est raccord -oui c'est vrai
carrément alors Rudy où est ce qu'on peut te voir dans une
pièce comme coussin aux cochons
comme au putain
tu veux pas dire le titre
c'est ça Rudy Milstein où est ce qu'on peut venir te voir sur scène
tu es au splendid dans cousins comme cochons
tu l'as bien dis parce que y a souvent des mecs qui se trompent quand il essaye de dire le titre
en fait un mélange de
de vaudeville
et de comédie musicale ouais c'est ça
et en fait ce que je ne savais pas c'est qu'avant les vaudevilles c'étais toujours musical
à c'est drôle donc en faite vous êtes revenu un peu à la source
oui c'est Nicolas Lumbreras l'auteur le metteur en scène
compositeur
qui a fais une parodie une
parodie des vaudevilles c'est très
drôle c'est extrêmement drôle
et Nicolas d’ailleurs qui
qui qui faisait partie des
4 personnes qui s'occupaient de la comédie des 3 bornes
la où j'ai commencé -exactement ah c'est vrai ah c'est drôle je savais pas illuminati tout s'est rejoins mec
je vais vous mettre le lien dans la description
et puis
et puis voilà c'est tout ce que
j'avais à dire -eh ben génial
y a pas de chaine Youtube
non donc abonnez-vous à la mienne à la place
évidemment j'imagine que vous aussi vous avez vos petites techniques
pour gérer le stress et les angoisses
mettez dans les commentaires on verra un
petit peu ce qui s'en dégage s'il y en a
qui ont des méthodes particulières
ou qui n'on rien à voir dans découvrir des nouvelles peut-être vous avez des super techniques
ah ben ouais -ou en faite ils ont des techniques complètement what the fuck
etça peu-être très drôle à lire et bien
rendez-vous demain à 17 heures puisque
mentalvlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc rendez-vous
demain à 17 heures chao
-dis chao -chao
mais du coup je suis pas du tout dans le même rythme que toi oui donc moi aussi je vais dire chao encore
chao